knowledge is crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients come from
and how they're produced the better so
ask lots of questions
and learn when it comes to buying pork
you can't do any better than ask a
butcher
and award winning master butcher danny
lidgate knows everything about the pig
from trotter to tail this family have
been in the meat business
for 150 years so this man really is on
the money
in comparison with other meats pork's
really good value you get some really
good cuts at really reasonable prices
and you can use everything from the tip
of the trotter down to the cheek
we can see here we've got the leg the
leg is about this region
really lean really good for things like
gammons and hams
coming down from the leg we've got the
loin and that's where the pork chops
come from
if you take the bones out you can bone
and roll it and you end up with
a really nice easy to cook cylinder of
meat really easy to carve carve like a
loaf of bread
coming away from the loin we've got the
belly and you can see what belly is
made up of fatty parts and meaty parts
don't be scared of the amount of fat
that's on it you need that fat to give
give the flavours coming through also
make sure you can possibly buy it with
the skin on the skin will crispen up
nicely give you good crackling
also add flavor into the fat
lower down from the bellies we've got
the shoulders
really the shoulders are a great meat
they're slightly fattier than the rest
of the animal
you can see with this pork shoulder the
amount of marbling you get in the
mussels the interior marbling
make sure you look for the marbling it's
essential for the flavour
and it's going to make a really good
eating experience
a pig there really is nothing to waste
the trust is even a really good flavor
because they're gelatinous qualities
and the meat can be really really
flavoursome also there's pigs cheeks
which obviously require a little bit
more cooking because of the use they get
but the flavors you're gonna get are
gonna be completely different to any
other part of a pig
pork is an incredibly versatile meat
they say the only part you can't eat
is the oink here's my guide to getting
the best out of familiar cuts
smoked or unsmoked bacon is not just for
breakfast
it's brilliant transforming salads gives
a real depth of flavour to stews
and is delicious in quick and easy pasta
dishes
the leg joint best known for ham also
makes inexpensive delicious sunday roast
and is great serve with peas pudding
and the tenderloin fill it incredibly
lean healthy
and fast to cook you can stuff it cut it
into scallops or strips that are perfect
for asian stir-fries
cooking dishes in advance is a brilliant
way of taking the stress out of cooking
at home
and many dishes just get better and
better with time
first up my amazing sticky pork ribs
one of the secrets to great cooking is
patience leaving dishes to marinade for
one or two days
helps to develop the flavor in your food
and the end result
so much more delicious it's a method i
use in the restaurants all the time
first off get your roasting tray put the
tray on the gas
pork ribs 60 meat and 35 40
fat give them a really good season salt
and pepper nice thing about this cut
they stay incredibly moist
when they're on the bone and the longer
you cook them the more delicious they
become
just push all that seasoning in to the
pork olive oil in
make sure that tray is nice and hot and
i really want that nice
sort of caramelization taking place on
the pork
that's the nice thing about starting it
on top of the stove use your roasting
tray
get them colored and then the oven
putting the ribs straight in the oven
you don't get the color it looks sort of
boiled as opposed to a nice caramelized
rib
ginger you can't beat fresh ginger with
sticky pork ribs
place it down nice and firmly and slice
the thinner you slice the ginger the
more fragrant
the ribs garlic
now it's really important before you add
anything to those ribs make sure you've
got the color
from the ribs first don't rush it turn
them over
that's what i want that nice crispy
color
as they sort of braise in the oven all
that color
just turns into the most amazing flavor
braising is just a chef's turn for
cooking something slowly in liquid
right ginger and garlic in spread it
around
on all those ribs to sort of roast the
ginger and the garlic
chili flakes chili flakes in next
sichuan pepper
citrusy vibrant peppercorns incredible
in next star anise that gives it a
really nice sort of anisd
flavor almost like you're roasting the
ribs in fennel
and now we've got the heat the spice
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
some fresh honey
honey glazes the pork beautifully
counteracts against all that spice in
there
but look what's happening a color on the
ribs is extraordinary
it's like a really nice chili sweet
caramel
now soy sauce brings that little bit of
sort of saltiness to it
really generous with the soy sauce
japanese vinegar
two tablespoons of vinegar in rice wine
it gives it that nice sort of tartness
the ribs
if you can't find rice wine our dry
sherry is a great substitute
300ml that takes out the heat of that
szechuan pepper
those dry chili flakes make sure they
all lay down like a nice
tight box of matches bring that up to
the boil
cooking is all about learning to develop
your own likes and dislikes
so always keep tasting to make sure
you're happy with a combination of
flavors
it's lacking a little touch of vinegar
what that sharpness now think what's
going on the tartness the heat the
caramel
the color on the ribs is amazing i want
a bit of a sort of
oniony flavor we'll put some springs in
whilst these ribs
are in the oven the spring onions will
sort of puree but give a sharpness
to the final taste of that pork
in with my spring onions and with my
stock
400 ml of stock this is just a
simple chicken stock the stock just sits
underneath the ribs it absorbs into the
rib
and the top of the rib glazes underneath
the rib
that gets crispy and rich and that's
what makes the ribs nice and moist
really important into the oven
cook at 180 for 30 minutes
then turn the ribs over and cook for a
further 30 minutes
[Music]
now wow they smell incredible
each side has got that really nice
crispy roasted edge
becomes sticky and chewy and sweet
sour the fats disappeared and the pork
just melts in your mouth
i want to take them to the next level
gas back on now
shake the tray and this is the sort of
the way that we finish them in the
restaurant
but every minute they glaze in that tray
they just get to taste better and better
now look at them i'm so happy with those
ribs done absolutely delicious now but
if you want
you can put them in the fridge and the
flavor will keep developing then just
reheat them when you want to serve
so each rib has a nice
slice of ginger on there
wow look at that delicious sticky ribs
with an amazing marinade